Hello, everyone.
I'm Nathan Martz.
I'm the developer PM
for the Daydream team.
And I'm here to talk to you
about enhancing applications
and websites with
embeddable VR views.
I'm sure all of you have
heard a great deal this week
about our brand new platform
for immersive long form VR,
Daydream.
Now, Daydream is amazing, and
you've heard a lot about it.
But today I'm going to talk to
you about a different mobile VR
platform from Google
called Cardboard.
And even though we're talking
a lot about Daydream today,
Cardboard is alive and well.
In part because it has some
really unique properties.
Cardboard still is the world's
most affordable and most widely
distributed VR platform.
It's really, really good
at bite size experiences.
It's something you can drop
into and drop out of really,
really comfortably.
It also works on my
iOS and on Android.
And it's super
easily branded if you
want to use it in a marketing
campaign or a give away.
And especially the
bite size nature
of the content, the fact
that you're not necessarily
locked into VR for a
long time with Cardboard
makes us think of some
interesting applications.
That's what I want to
talk to you about today.
Also the heart of Cardboard,
and of Daydream in general,
is this idea of VR for everyone.
And when we say that we mean
not just VR for every user,
but actually we mean
for every developer,
and also hopefully
for every business.
Google is investing
in VR because we
believe it's a potentially
transformative technology.
And so we're always
thinking for ways
to apply that technology
outside of the most obvious
applications of games and
media, into the real world,
into the businesses that
most of us run and support.
And with that I'd
like to talk to you
about a specific insight,
a specific opportunity
we've been thinking about.
So imagine you have
a travel website.
Now, travel is a huge part of
internet search and commerce.
People spend tremendous
amounts of time and money
when they try to
plan their vacations.
And today, whether it's
an app or a website,
we do the best we can
with the tools available.
So if you want to tell
someone about Machu Picchu,
we have a beautiful photograph.
And we have text and copy that
tries to support that, maybe
some charts and graphs.
But if you're traveling
to Machu Picchu
you'd really like
to know what it
feels like to be on
top of the mountain,
to look around the ruins.
It'd be so much
more amazing if you
could feel like you're immersed
in that space, physically
present.
If you're planning a
trip to Machu Picchu
and you're like, ah, that's what
it looks like, it's so amazing,
you might be more
likely to travel there.
And this idea of
embedding immersive media
into more traditional websites
and applications we think
is actually a very
large opportunity,
and not just for travel.
For example, if
you're in real estate,
maybe you're a home
builder, your whole business
is you have to sell homes
that haven't been built yet.
And some people are going
to come to your office,
and they're going to be
excited about your home,
but they're going to walk out
the door because they have
a hard time buying
a house if they
can't look around
the kitchen and then
walk to the living room.
Well, embeddable immersive
media could let you do that.
If you're in retail,
or support retail,
you want to have somebody design
a room, or look at a show room
without leaving the
comfort of their home.
You can do that with
immersive media.
Maybe you work in
news and you want
to really leverage the power
of VR as the empathy machine,
to bring people into the stories
in a really remarkable way.
Immersive media can
do that as well.
And of course education
is another opportunity,
where if you want to take
your students on virtual field
trips, teach them about the
world, take them to places
they could never go that are
thousands or millions of miles
away.
This is all possible.
And so we know that
even though there's
this great potential most
businesses and most developers
don't have a large team
of VR experts on standby
just waiting for this
stuff to happen, right.
Building a VR app from the
ground up is expensive.
But we want to
make it accessible.
And that's why I'm
here to talk to you
about a technology released
just a couple months ago
called VR Views.
And I'll tell you about it
in a great deal of detail
over the next half hour.
So it's much easier
to experience VR Views
than it is just to
talk about them.
So if anyone has a smartphone,
I suspect a few of you
have these crazy things
called smartphones,
there's a short URL
which will take you
to a live version of this demo.
So check it out.
I'll leave the URL up
for just another second.
It's pretty fricken cool.
And bonus points if you actually
brought a Cardboard, or a VR
viewer of your choice.
Even better.
So the starting point for VR
Views is an embedded window.
We know that most apps are not
going to start users in VR.
You're going to start in 2D.
And you want to bring this
window into an immersive world.
You want to bring it to users
even before they've entered VR.
In fact, we know
that, of course,
not everyone has a Cardboard
with them all the time.
And if you're going to
build this technology
and integrate it
into your site, you
want it to work in
VR and outside of VR.
The cool thing is that with the
embedded Magic Window on mobile
when you move your
phone around you'll
see that the picture
actually responds.
It's alive.
You're looking through
this magic window
into this other world.
Now, from there you've
got a couple of choices.
There's a full screen
button in the lower right.
And if you press that
you get Magic Window,
but in full screen.
It's the most immerses you
can get without Cardboard.
Now, of course, the best
option is the VR option.
And if you press that you
get stereoscopic real time
viewing designed to
be compatible with all
of our Cardboard viewers.
And the cool thing
about VR is it's
the most immersive, especially
if you have stereo 360 content.
And we'll talk about how you
can capture your own stereo 360
content in just a little bit.
So, of course, it's great to
talk about what it can do,
but how do you use it, right.
You're developers.
You want to know,
how do I actually
get this into my website
or into my application.
And I'm really proud to tell you
that pretty much everywhere you
want to be VR Views
already supports.
We have a web based
implementation that works
on desktop and mobile browsers.
We have native
Android integrations
through our Google VR SDK, and
native iOS integrations also
through the Google VR SDK.
So regardless of whether you
have an app or a website,
whether you're a
desktop or mobile,
you can use this technology,
use the same content
across all of those
services, and integrate it
with a minimum of effort.
In fact, one of the
hard parts with VR Views
is actually compatibility.
Right, when you
talk about browsers
alone there's lots of
different browsers.
Well, we support all of the
leading browsers across all
the major operating systems.
As long as you have a relatively
recent version of the browser.
I'm sorry.
IE6, not supported.
But otherwise we're pretty good.
On Android we have
support for everything
from KitKat and on up, and on
iOS everything from iOS 8.0
and up.
It's a really, really wide
range of compatibility.
The majority of the
users you want to reach.
We've done the hard work
to do the compatibility.
And not just the compatibility,
also the performance work,
to make sure that
this doesn't just
work but it's fast
and responsive,
which is super important,
especially in VR.
So integrations are
fortunately super simple.
If you want to integrate a
VR view into your website,
it's basically like
integrating a YouTube video.
You add an iframe.
The most important field
is that source field,
where you can reference
either scripts that we've
staged and hosted on Google
Cloud Storage, or scripts
that you host yourself.
The web version is
all open source.
So super simple.
The GitHub link is at
the bottom of the page.
And then you tell us where
to find the 360 degree image,
and there you go.
We do recommend that if
you're trying this out
for the first time using our
scripts that we host is great.
But you'll run into things
like cross site cores issues.
You'll have to
think about things
like browser compatibility
in a couple of cases.
So if you host the script on
the same site as the content
it's much easier.
We highly recommend you do that
in any production environment.
On Android it's
also super simple.
You'll add your view to
your layout XML file.
In code you just
find that layout.
In the case of an image you
create a new bitmap factory,
tell it what file to open.
And then you just need to get
the options for the VR view.
In this case the
VR panorama view.
Tell us whether it's a
stereo or a mono image.
And then give the
raw bitmap data,
hand it off to the widget.
Just that simple.
And iOS, very similarly
all you have to do
is allocate a new VR view,
tell it what image to load,
and then add the VR
view as a sub view
to whatever your
larger container is.
Again, super simple,
very idiomatic.
We tried very hard to make
sure that this stuff is not
just simple but
expressed in a way
that's natural for the platform
that you're developing for.
And, again, in all these
slides I've got GitHub links.
Super easy to find.
And I'll reference them
again at the end of the talk.
So one of the questions we
get is it's like, OK, great,
like VR view is awesome, and it
seems really easy to integrate.
But how do you get the content?
Like even capturing in
360 is relatively new.
Well, I'm happy
to say that there
are some extremely affordable
options on the market.
And I'll walk through a
handful of them today.
So before I talk about
specific capture solutions
I want to get a little
bit of terminology, which
was the difference between
inside out capture and outside
in capture.
Everything we're going to talk
about today is inside out.
Which means that the capture
is taken from a single point
looking outwards.
And just like when you're
in VR in Cardboard,
it's really good to be in a
point looking out to the world.
Outside in is the
opposite of that.
It's using a lot of like
scanning configurations.
But for all of VR
View you really want
to be using inside out capture,
not outside in capture,
and thinking about use cases
that are inside out rather
than outside in.
As an example of that,
in retail something
like a showroom for home
decorating, that's inside out.
You're standing in
the room looking
at the drapes and the couch.
Something like
shopping for shoes
is more outside in, where
you want to look at the shoe,
rotate it in your hand,
or you're effectively
moving around the object
rather than looking
from the inside out.
So one of the cheapest,
because it's free,
and awesome ways to capture
not just 360 but stereo 360
is to use our Cardboard
Camera app on Android.
It's super easy to use.
And it's one of the best ways
to capture 360 stereo imagery.
There's a download link in
the short URL on the bottom.
Now, if you want to use
the Cardboard Camera
app with VR View you need
to do a format conversion.
Cardboard Camera is very clever
and it packs the left eye
and right eye data
together in a way
that you need to unpack in
order to use in VR View.
So we have a really
simple website
that we've put together that
lets you just drag and drop
an image from Cardboard Camera.
We'll automatically convert
it and prep it for a format
that VR View can take.
So, again, super simple.
Use the app.
Use the converter.
And then you're ready
to go for VR View.
Another great, really affordable
option is the Ricoh Theta.
This is, I think, one of the
simplest 360 capture options
around right now.
The only limitation is
that it's monoscopic.
So in the way that Cardboard
Camera supports stereo 360,
Ricoh supports only mono 360.
But it supports capturing both
video and still photography.
Now, of course, we've talked a
lot about real world contexts.
But VR views are not actually
limited to the real world,
right.
CG is a great source.
In fact, if you're that
hypothetical home builder who
wants to show people what
the home will look like,
you're probably going
to be capturing your 360
views from renderers of
your architectural drawings.
And there's a lot of great
plugins for everything
from game engines like
Unreal Engine and Unity,
to more traditional
offline rendering
tools like Renderman and Maya.
And these plugins generate
the same standardized format
that VR View supports.
So let's talk a little bit about
the specifics of the formats
that work in VR View.
So the most basic format we
support is a mono 360 pano.
It looks like that.
Some people will call
it a lat-long image
or an equirect pano.
It's a very, very
standardized format.
Almost anything that can do
360 will output that format.
And we also support its stereo
cousin, which you'll often hear
called an ODS, an
Omnidirectional Stereo.
Which is really just two
panos, one for each eye,
stacked on top of each other.
So a stereo image looks very
much like a model image,
except two eyes in one
image rather than one.
We also support in the first
version both images and videos.
So 360 stills, 360 videos,
and of course mono and stereo
of both of them.
For images specifically, if
you have a mono 360 image
you want your aspect
ratio to be two to one.
So, for example, 1,024 x
2,048 is a good baseline
for mono 360.
In stereo it's one to one.
It's a square.
Because you're stacking a two by
one image on top of another two
by one image.
For performance and
compatibility reasons
the maximum dimensions
are 4,096 x 4,096.
That's especially
critical on mobile.
And we support
both JPEG and PNG.
Although generally we recommend
JPEG for faster download sizes,
especially for anything that
looks very photographic.
On the video side of
things we strongly
recommend you stick to MP4 H.264
with a 16 x 9 aspect ratio.
One interesting
thing on video is
that the device
support for video
is much more varied,
especially on mobile,
than it is for imagery.
On pretty much any modern
phone a 4,096 x 4,096 texture
will work.
What you'll find
though with video
is that some phones cap out
at 1080p, whereas other phones
will decode up to 4k.
So what we recommend
generally is
that if you want one thing
that works everywhere
use a mono 1080p 16 x
9 video for your 360.
However, if you want to
target higher end devices
and support stereo,
you may want to have
two versions, that simple
monoscopic version that
works everywhere and
then a higher fidelity,
ideally 2160p version
for the maximum quality,
deliver to devices that
you know support it.
One last really funny
quirk with video
is that there's a wide variety
of resolutions that work.
But you want to make
sure your dimensions,
your length and your width,
are always divisible by 16.
That's due to specifics
and how hardware decoders
work on mobile phones.
So I think that's a
really great overview
of how all of this stuff works.
We've talked about the
applications, whether you're
a home builder, or a
journalist, or in retail.
And we've got a lot
of great resources
if you want to learn more.
So we have a Getting
Started Guide
on developers.google.com/vr.
And we have actually two really
great code labs here at I/O.
So you've only got
a few hours left.
But I highly encourage you to
check out one of the kiosks.
They're really
well put together.
But if you're not able to get
to it in time for today's I/O,
they'll all be available online.
And they really
help you understand
the basics of getting in
there, creating an app,
creating a website,
and making it better
with embeddable VR media.
So thank you so
much for the time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]